et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
François-Xavier Bellamy bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous des
plutôt européen vice-président exécutif
des républicains on a évidemment
beaucoup de sujets abordés avec vous on
commence parce qu'il s'est passé hier à
Nanterre ou un jeune homme de 17 ans a
été tué lors d'un contrôle routier le
policier a tiré après un refus
d'obtempérer une vidéo circulant sur les
réseaux sociaux montre que le policier
tire quand la voiture redémarre
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti en
voyant cette vidéo
évidemment c'est toujours terrible
qu'une vie soit perdue et bien sûr bien
sûr il faudra que la justice fasse toute
la lumière sur les circonstances de cet
événement
mais moi je suis révolté de voir à quel
point certains y compris dans la classe
politique
saisissent cette occasion pour condamner
immédiatement les policiers au point
qu'on a même le sentiment qu'il voudrait
nous faire croire que les policiers de
la République rêvent de rentrer chez eux
le soir en ayant tué un jeune si ce
jeune est mort qui rappelons-le roulait
sans permis qui certainement par son
comportement routier avait dû attirer
l'attention de ces agents de police si
ce jeune est mort c'est d'abord parce
qu'il a cherché à se soustraire à un
contrôle et que les conséquences de ce
comportement aurait pu être
potentiellement dramatique pour d'autres
personnes à proximité pour d'autres
potentiels victimes d'une comportement
c'est justifie d'être tué d'une balle à
bout portant mais encore une fois il
faut que l'enquête fasse son travail
bien sûr
mais je crois que aucun policier
n'utilise son arme de gaieté de cœur et
qu'on voit dans les émeutes
injustifiable qui ont émaillé cette nuit
à Nanterre parce que rien jamais de
justifie qu'on s'entraîne notamment à
des policiers mais pas seulement à des
policiers à des biens publics à des
biens privés qu'on s'entraîne à des
personnes qui pourraient être devenir
les prochaines victimes de ce qui est en
train de se passer rien ne justifie
cette accès de violence mais tout cela
est alimenté par un certain discours et
je le redis un certain discours
politique on a entendu ces derniers mois
ces dernières années dans tant de
manifestations
le slogan que tout le monde déteste la
police on a entendu des responsables
politiques d'extrême gauche nous dire
que la police tue que la police
assassine comme si les policiers
pouvaient être rangés au rang des
criminels et moi je voudrais dire une
dernière chose de la gauche venant vous
les connaissez de députés de la France
insoumise qui se sont exprimés encore
hier venant de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
lui-même
on devrait tous être d'accord pour dire
que ça n'est évidemment pas normal
qu'une intervention de police se termine
de cette manière là et je pense que les
policiers sont les premiers à le
reconnaître encore une fois c'est
vraiment dans des cas d'extrême
nécessité qu'un policier peut être
conduit à employer la force d'une
manière aussi radicale et cela
évidemment constituer un drame et je
pense bien sûr à tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui sur le terrain policier
gendarme sont en première ligne face à
cette violence qui monte je pense
évidemment aussi à tous ceux qui ont été
touchés par la mort de ce jeune homme
mais à la fin j'ai quand même une
question à poser
comment se fait-il qu'on en arrive à
vivre dans un pays où des jeunes sont
capables même pas encore majeurs et
peut-être y a-t-il là une part du
problème sont capables de se soustraire
à l'ordre d'un policier qui leur demande
de s'arrêter même quand ce policier se
croit dans une situation suffisamment
tendue pour sortir son arme de service
la première chose qu'on devrait être
tous dire et la première chose qu'on
devrait tous dire et je pense d'ailleurs
en particulier aux parents la première
chose que tout le monde devrait dire aux
enfants de ce pays c'est que si un
policier un gendarme vous demande de
vous arrêter il est investi de la force
publique il a une mission de service
public son autorité c'est l'autorité de
l'État et vous devez l'écouter ça nous
est arrivé à tous de connaître des
contrôles routiers il est absolument
anormal que des jeunes de 17 ans soient
à ce point victime parce que c'est d'une
certaine manière aussi le résultat d'un
mouvement de très grande ampleur victime
d'une telle faillite éducative d'une
éducative et notamment encore une fois
de la part des familles qu'ils soient
capables qu'ils soient capables de
chercher à défier des policiers en
uniforme qui leur intime l'ordre de
s'arrêter et si ce jeune s'était arrêté
et si il avait obtempéré et bien nous
n'en serions pas là aujourd'hui et il
est certain qu'il ne serait pas mort
parce que je leur ai dit aucun policier
n'utilise son arme de service de gaieté
de cœur les tensions qui ont eu lieu
hier à Nanterre et dans les villes
alentours elles ne s'explique pas parce
qu'il y a chez certains jeunes un
sentiment que il y a une forme
d'impunité dans la police mais le
sentiment d'impunité pardonnez-moi je le
vois dans le fait que ce jeune
conducteur sans permis à 17 ans se croit
autorisé à redémarrer son véhicule alors
que deux agents de police en moto l'ont
suivi pour lui demander de s'arrêter le
sentiment d'impunité il est là et ce
sentiment d'impunité il tue
et encore une fois je ne préjuge pas des
conclusions de l'enquête mais à la fin
qu'aurions-nous dit si les policiers
avaient laissé ce jeune homme repartir
et que dans un comportement routier
manifestement dangereux il avait tué sur
sa route des innocents
la justice doit faire son travail et je
le redis les policiers les gendarmes se
savent à investi d'une mission
d'autorité publique qui évidemment leur
confère une responsabilité immense et je
crois qu'évidemment cette responsabilité
doit être exercée de manière
proportionnelle que la justice fasse son
travail c'est la moindre des choses elle
le fait d'ailleurs mais ça n'est pas en
semant la violence dans des quartiers
entiers que l'on obtiendra justice et
dans une société démocratique on devrait
aussi pouvoir le rappeler Emmanuel
Macron était en visite à Marseille il
est toujours en visite à Marseille
aujourd'hui mais hier il était en
visite chez colle il veut repenser le
temps scolaire il dit que c'est une
hypocrisie française il faut des
vacances plus courtes notamment l'été et
des semaines plus légères c'est ce qui
souhaite faire vous approuvez le chef de
l'État là-dessus
je ne savais pas que le chef de l'État a
été ministre de tout mais manifestement
il est capable de rentrer dans le détail
de l'organisation de toutes les
administrations du pays
la chose essentielle c'est que
précisément on attend le chef de l'État
pour ne pas s'occuper des détails et ce
qui n'est pas en détail ça n'est pas la
question de la répartition du temps
scolaire et du temps des vacances ce qui
n'est pas en détail c'est ce qui se
passe dans le temps scolaire
et le fait que précisément avec le temps
dont elle dispose l'école ne transmet
plus aux enfants de ce pays l'essentiel
dont ils ont besoin pour pouvoir
construire leur vie l'école ne sait plus
apprendre aux enfants de notre pays à
lire à écrire à compter c'est cela qui
devrait supposer l'investissement massif
du président de la République pas la
question de savoir s'il faut une semaine
de vacances de plus ou moins
pendant plus de 10 ans et qui espèrent
le redevenir c'est un métier magnifique
mais quand vous êtes prof depuis votre
salle de classe quand vous constatez
l'effondrement de l'éducation nationale
il y a quelque chose de surréaliste à
entendre toujours ces mêmes débats
complètement superficiel parfois c'est
une semaine de vacances en plus ou moins
parfois c'est le poids du cartable
parfois c'est l'uniforme à l'école j'ai
envie de dire tout ça et ridicule le
sujet majeur c'est comment est-ce que
nous allons reconstruire un système qui
est aujourd'hui en train de s'effondrer
sur lui-même malgré le dévouement des
professeurs malgré le mouvement des prof
qui et ça aussi c'est un sujet d'alerte
maximale dont le président de la
République devrait s'occuper les
professeurs qui aujourd'hui sont en
train petit à petit de déserter
l'éducation nationale parce qu'ils ont
le sentiment que leur métier est vidé de
son sens par une structure à bout de
souffle quand on leur propose une sorte
de pacte qui n'a aucun sens pour pouvoir
les augmenter en les faisant travailler
plus comme si au fond ça n'est pas leur
travail qui devait être reconnu quand on
voit aujourd'hui et ça c'est un sujet je
crois il faut le retenir aujourd'hui
parce que nous en parlerons beaucoup
dans les années qui viendront qui
devraient tous nous inquiéter quand on
voit aujourd'hui la pénurie de
professeurs dans les concours de
recrutement je sais bien que le
gouvernement l'inifiant pendant que le
président parle du nombre de vacances le
gouvernement l’énifiant nous explique
que tout va bien mais non tout ne va pas
bien sur 8000 postes ouverts pour le
concours de recrutement des professeurs
de premier degré des instituteurs
institutrices il manque aujourd'hui 1250
recruter nous avons aujourd'hui une
pénurie d'évocations gigantesque qui
touche maintenant toutes les disciplines
qui touchent tous les niveaux de
l'enseignement et bien dans quelques
années nous n'aurons tout simplement
plus de professeurs à mettre devant des
élèves c'est ça qui devrait inquiéter le
président de la République mais je vois
bien à quel point c'est facile de faire
diversion vous lancer le sujet des
vacances dans le département et bien sûr
mais les vacances c'est un sujet
passionné tout le monde parle des
vacances alors c'est parti
non mais la vraie inégalité sociale
c'est encore une fois pas le temps des
vacances c'est ce qui se passe à l'école
la vraie inégalité sociale c'est que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
lui-même a tellement conscience de la
crise de l'école qu'il met ses enfants
dans l'enseignement privé le plus
sélectif le plus élitiste le plus
resserré sociologiquement du centre de
la capitale c'est ça la vraie inégalité
sociale c'est pas ce qui se passe pour
les vacances c'est ce qui se passe à
l'école aujourd'hui et c'est le fait
qu'à l'école tous les enfants ne se pays
n'ont pas les mêmes chances d'apprendre
ce qui est pourtant essentiel la culture
de notre pays les éléments fondamentaux
de la lecture de l'écriture
climatique des sciences de la
rationalité et pendant ce temps-là et
pendant ce temps la pardonnez-moi mais
que fait ce gouvernement la première
ministre explique que maintenant on va
faire une certification verte on nous
explique qu'on va augmenter le temps de
d'apprentissage des valeurs civiques la
clé absolue c'est de revenir à
l'enseignement des savoirs fondamentaux
c'est la seule augmente aussi la
rémunération des professeurs pour
essayer de les attirer encore une fois
on leur disant qu'il va falloir qu'ils
signent un pacte qui n'a ni que ni tête
qui est une manière d'ailleurs de
pallier cette absence de recrutement
c'est difficulté ces tensions sur la
mobilisation du du personnel enseignant
qu'est-ce que vous diriez si votre
patron vous disait écoute je vois bien
que tu es sous payé je veux bientôt
augmenter parce que c'est le cas les
professeurs français sont sous-payés au
regard des statistiques européennes je
vois bien que tu es sous payé je veux
bien augmenter mais à condition que tu
travailles plus mais vous diriez je suis
méprisé et à raison vous le diriez et si
en plus on vous demandait de signer pour
une
usine à gaz absurde qui va encore plus
vous rendre difficile le fait tout
simplement de faire votre travail tout
les formes d'infériorisation des femmes
notamment dans le sport qui justement
est un lieu où chacun devrait vivre
cette aspiration à l'égalité dans la
dans la compétition sportive mais le
fait est que aujourd'hui nous voyons
combien notre droit est retourné contre
lui-même combien nos principes
républicains sont retournés contre la
culture de notre propre pays cette
culture d'égalité cette culture qui
refuse l'asservissement il faudrait au
contraire la consacrer par la loi et en
fait pourquoi en sommes-nous là
si le Conseil d'État demande à l'affaire
de changer son rayonnement ils l'ont
déjà fait ils ont déposé des amendements
au Sénat
on déposerait une loi mais pardon c'est
très important ces amendements pourquoi
ne sont-ils pas passés ils ne sont pas
passés dans la loi parce que la majorité
macroniste s'étalit avec la gauche pour
les refuser c'est exactement le même
scénario que nous voyons au Parlement
européen lorsque j'ai déposé un
amendement pour interdire à la
Commission européenne de continuer de
financer des publicités qui disaient
souvenez-vous la joie est dans le hijab
ou bien la liberté est dans le hijab ou
bien apporter de la joie accepter le
hijab c'était les slogans financés par
la Commission européenne lorsque j'ai
déposé un amendement pour mettre fin à
ce scandale et bien des députés
macronistes se sont alliés avec les
députés de la gauche pour empêcher que
c'est amendement soit mis aux voix à
force de persévérance nous avons fini
par y parvenir et nous avons fini par
réunir une majorité autour de cette
amendement et aujourd'hui nous avons
marqué ce point et gagner cette bataille
mais pourtant Gérald Darmanin lui il se
dit très opposé à la demande des femmes
qui veulent porter le hijab on appelle
ça le en même temps des ministres qui
font des déclarations pour plaire à la
majorité des électeurs français qui
voient bien qui voit bien la folie de
cette situation dans laquelle nos
institutions comme le Conseil d'État se
mettent à promouvoir une idéologie
réactionnaire l'islamisme le plus
obscurantiste qui veut enfermer les
femmes derrière des voiles on voit bien
évidemment tous les Français le voient à
quel point il y a là une transgression
très grave mais derrière les
déclarations supposées du gouvernement
la majorité macroniste elle un effet
obstacle à tout ce qui permettrait de
lutter contre cette dérive
mais bien sûr nous continuons nous nous
continuerons de mettre les élus devant
le responsabilité sur quoi vous
redéposerez un instant que nos collègues
à l'Assemblée nationale s'ils
conseillent l'état devait procéder à
cette funeste décision inspirer
d’ailleurs évidemment par les
nominations récentes de ce gouvernement
le président de la République savait ce
qu'il faisait quand il ne met par
exemple Thierry tuot un poste de
responsabilité très important au sein du
Conseil d'État Thierry tuot et c'est son
droit le plus entier il a une ligne
politique qui est connue de tout le
monde il est multiculturaliste il
considère que défendre les valeurs de la
République c'est déjà une forme
réactionnaire et dangereuse de de
protection de notre identité de la même
manière que quand le président de la
République nomme monsieur papenga et
ministre de l'éducation nationale il
sait très bien ce qu'il fait aussi
chacun doit assumer sa responsabilité
oui le débat est claire il faut sortir
durant même temps maintenant il y a ceux
qui défendent effectivement le fait
qu'on renonce à nos valeurs pour voiler
les femmes en France y compris sur les
terrains de sport et la majorité
macroniste fait partie de cela et il y a
quelques mois vous allez dire au
macroniste de ce de se positionner mais
encore une fois nous l'avons déjà fait
et nous le referons nous le referons
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons obtenu gain de
cause parce que l'enjeu est trop
important et l'enjeu je le dis là encore
comme prof c'est la liberté des femmes
c'est la liberté des jeunes filles de ce
pays aujourd'hui j'entends celle qui
explique avec leur vol sur la tête que
il y a une discrimination en France
parce qu'elle ne peuvent pas jouer voler
la véritable discrimination je vais vous
dire c'est celle que subissent tant de
jeune fille dans notre pays dans bien
des quartiers de notre pays qui
voudraient pouvoir enlever le voile mais
qui savent que ce n'est pas possible
parce que la pression sociale est trop
forte autre sujet la nomination de
Geoffroy le jeune à la tête de la
rédaction du Journal du Dimanche fait
beaucoup parler et ça a déclenché une
grève dans la rédaction hier une tribune
a été signée par des centaines de
personnalités le JDD ne peut devenir un
journal au service des idées d'extrême
droite c'est ce qui est dit qu'en
dites-vous
écoutez c'est très intéressant comme
discussion moi je serai évidemment
curieux que RSF qui coordonnait cette
tribune et la soirée qui avait lieu hier
en soutien en opposition à la nomination
de Geoffroy Lejeune je serai très
intéressé caresse nous fasse peut-être
une liste des gens qui sont autorisés à
diriger une rédaction dans ce pays parce
que comme ça au moins ce serait plus
rapide vous voyez en éviterait de de se
retrouver dans des situations d'impact
qu'on nous dise voilà qui qui peut-être
a le droit de s'engager dans le
journalisme et qui n'a pas le droit
voyez je ferai le jeune on peut être ou
pas d'accord avec ses idées mais le fait
est qu'il n'est même pas encore nommé si
il y a des choses à reprocher à la façon
dont il dirige une rédaction quand il
sera devenu le patron du JDD et bien
évidemment il faut que ceux qui peut
être critiquable soit critiqué mais il
n'est même pas encore nommé qu'il n'a
pas le droit supposément de prendre ses
fonctions moi j'écoutais vous savez
des idées notamment durant la campagne
présidentielle pour vous déposer un
problème qui dirige la rédaction du JDD
encore une fois il a ses idées je ne le
conteste pas mais il y a beaucoup de
gens dans le monde médiatique qui ont
des idées qui sont différentes par
exemple des miennes je ne leur conteste
pas le fait de faire leur travail y
compris d'ailleurs pardonnez-moi de le
dire y compris sur le service public que
je finance par mes impôts comme tous les
contribuables français j'entendais par
exemple il y a quelques heures c'était
hier Laura de l'air votre concert de
France Inter dont j'ai écouté et je le
dis sans acrimonie parce que j'ai écouté
avec avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme ses
émissions pendant des années et elle
quitte aujourd'hui ses fonctions avec
beaucoup d'élégance elle devenait livrer
son témoignage au micro de France Inter
et elle disait au moment de prendre
congé de sa longue carrière
journalistique dans le service public
elle disait je suis fier d'être de
gauche j'ai été de gauche toute ma vie
je le suis encore aujourd'hui la
question que je me pose c'est et c'est
la question que pose fondamentalement le
débat que nous avons est-ce que
un journaliste une journaliste pourrait
conclure sa carrière par exemple sur le
service public en disant je suis fier
d'être de droite et je l'ai été toute ma
vie
voilà mais je crois qu'il y a un vrai
sujet de pluralisme
de droite je ne sais pas exactement à
quel moment on glisse de la
caractérisation vers la thème mais le
fait était encore une fois qu'il n'a
même pas encore pu prendre ses fonctions
Geoffre le jeune il est journaliste il a
interviewé des personnalités de tous les
bords politiques il a interviewé des
gens qui ont répondu à ces questions qui
venaient de la France insoumise qui
venait de la gauche classique
est-ce qu'il est si infréquentable que
le Président de la République a répondu
malgré tout à ces questions enfin
écoutez il y a quelque chose de
révoltant là-dedans et pardonnez-moi de
le dire il y a quelque chose aussi
d'assez inquiétant parce que derrière ce
débat en fait ce que dit ce monde
médiatique et intellectuel
tous les lecteurs et les électeurs
français c'est qu'il y a une partie de
l'électorat en France une partie du
lectorat qui n'aurait tout simplement
pas droit de citer
dans le paysage du débat intellectuel de
la vie civique et évidemment dans le
paysage médiatique
jusqu'à maintenant c'est un journal
indépendant c'était pas un journal
d'opinion est-ce que ça ne vous poserait
pas de problème que ça devienne un
client quand on parle à vos confrères on
a souvent le sentiment que c'est
d'ailleurs parfaitement admis que le JDD
c'était le journal dans lequel le
gouvernement lançait ses prochaines
pistes ces prochaines idées c'est
prochaines bulles bon voilà ça fait
partie du jeu il faut qu'il y ait des
médias de tous les bords il faut qu'il y
ait des médias de toutes les
sensibilités justement de toutes les
sensibilités et il y a absolument pas de
raison je crois qu'il y ait une vision
du monde qui soit a priori exclue de la
possibilité d'intervenir dans le débat
médiatique
des rédactions à la nomination par un
actionnaire d'un directeur d'une
rédaction est-ce que c'est une piste à
explorer pour vous mais un journal ça
reste une activité économique pas comme
les autres bien sûr et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il y a un droit de la
presse qui est d'ailleurs heureusement
très protecteur du métier journaliste
qui est un métier que je respecte
infiniment et qui est absolument
nécessaire à la vie démocratique c'est
la raison pour laquelle la liberté de
conscience d'un journaliste est
absolument respectée et quand un
actionnaire nouveau change de direction
à la ligne d'un journal et bien les
journalistes comme vous le savez ont
droit de faire valoir ce qu'on appelle
une clause de cession ils ont droit de
quitter la rédaction si il ne se sente
plus en phase avec l'orientation qu'elle
prend voilà ça c'est la liberté
journalistique mais à la fin malgré tout
ce serait quand même étonnant que celui
qui
dirige une entreprise fut-elle une
entreprise de presse n'est pas la
possibilité d'orienter les décisions
qu'il prend à la tête de cette de cette
société et
il nous reste peu de temps
François-Xavier BMI Nicolas Sarkozy on
passe un autre sujet Nicolas Sarkozy a
déjeuné hier avec des parlementaires de
l'aile droite de renaissance y compris
des parlementaires venus de vous rend il
y a Damien Badi avait conscience le grip
il y avait romain Reda que pensez-vous
de cette initiative
Nicolas Sarkozy déjeune avec qui il veut
hein pour le reste quel est le droit de
renaissance je reviens à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure ça m'intéresse de
savoir ce que pense l'aile droite de
renaissance du fait que c'est grâce à
Renaissance l'aile droite de renaissance
du fait que c'est grâce à Renaissance
que précisément aujourd'hui le Conseil
d'État s'apprête à décider que le hijab
est légitime sur les terrains de sport
ça m'intéresse beaucoup Sarkozy il dit
aider Emmanuel Macron s'est aidé la
France
écoutez c'est très curieux comme formule
est-ce que Nicolas Sarkozy aurait dit
aider François Hollande c'est aider la
France la ligne politique d'un président
de la République et de sa majorité ne se
confondent pas nécessairement avec
l'intérêt national c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui fait que nous sommes en démocratie
si le président de la République était
forcément la voix de
de la promesse de l'espérance et du
Salut du pays ça voudrait dire en fait
que les partis politiques d'opposition
sont nuisibles moi je crois au contraire
que dans une démocratie il arrive que le
président puisse se tromper il arrive
que sa majorité et en l'occurrence
justement c'est peut-être une manière de
renoncer à la démocratie de considérer
qu'effectivement il y a absolument pas
d'alternative possible mais pardon de le
dire en l'occurrence la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron de son gouvernement et
de sa majorité sont en réalité plus à
gauche que la politique menée par
François Hollande a bien des égards
qu'est-ce que pense l'aile droite de la
macronie du fait que aujourd'hui par
exemple notre pays a plus aggraver son
endettement et que sa fiscalité a plus
explosé pendant la période macroniste
que pendant la période socialiste
qu'est-ce que l'aile droite supposer du
macronisme à dire du fait qu'aujourd'hui
au Parlement européen ce sont les
députés macronistes qui bataillent par
exemple pour interdire que l'Europe se
renforce face au flux migratoires
illégaux j'entends Nicolas Sarkozy qui
dit paraît-il député macroniste oh là là
la crise migratoire n'a pas encore
commencé et bien moi je suis d'accord
avec ça mais le fait est que ce sont les
députés macronistes qui nous empêchent
de nous protéger face aux crises
migratoires futures qu'est-ce que l'aile
droite de la macronie à dire du fait
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des députés
Parlement européen qui organise la
décroissance des économies européennes
au nom d'un agenda d'écologie politique
instrumentalisée par Pascal Campin qui
voudrait interdire aux agriculteurs de
continuer à cultiver rendre des terres à
l'affiche nous empêcher de protéger et
d'entretenir nos forêts empêcher les
pêcheurs de pêcher qui voudraient
interdire que l'industrie y compris
l'industrie des carbonées puissent se
déployer sur le terrain de notre pays et
du continent européen c'est une
politique de décroissance c'est une
politique de lutte contre tout ce qui
protège l'Europe face aux flux
migratoire c'est une politique qui
contribue à fragiliser les valeurs de
notre pays c'est une politique de gauche
alors après on peut en penser ce qu'on
veut Nicolas Sarkozy a le droit d'être
macroniste moi je ne sais pas
rester dans notre famille politique où
est-ce qu'il approche une belle ligne
rouge hier très longtemps de toute façon
qu'il a expliqué et c'est son droit le
plus entier qu'ils se sentait
aujourd'hui dans le camp du président de
la République très bien s'il en est un
soutien c'est la démocratie chacun fait
ses choix je fais des choix différents
et mon camp politique aussi vous parlez
beaucoup de est-ce que vous serez
peut-être de liste européenne on verra
si dans un an on a encore le temps le
plus important pour moi c'est d'abord de
travailler à une stratégie collective
avec erikiotti nous y travaillons nous
avons envie de l'être moi j'ai envie que
mon pays puisse retrouver une voix forte
en Europe c'est la seule chose
pour moi c'est pas un sujet personnel on
est dans un moment tellement important
tellement grave dans la vie de notre
pays et aussi dans l'histoire de
l'Europe que je me sentirai scandaleux
si je ramenais cette question à ma
petite personne le sujet de ma personne
et de ma trajectoire personnelle le
compte pas la seule chose qui compte
c'est effectivement
de famille politique et encore une fois
le sujet pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
concentre toujours sur des questions de
de personnes et d'ailleurs ce sera pas
seulement la question de la tête de
liste ce sera la question de la liste
dans son ensemble mais c'est sûr
est-ce que vous avez un espace avec
votre ligne entre eux Emmanuel Macron
entre et sûrement avec reconquête qui
risque de vous prendre des voix bon ça
c'est au sondeur de dire s'il y a un
espace moi je dis pas qu'on a un espace
j'en sais rien je suis pas là pour
additionner des clientèles électorales
ce que je crois c'est qu'on a un devoir
on a un devoir parce qu'il y a
effectivement aujourd'hui un travail qui
n'est pas fait ni par la macronie qui
comme je le disais à l'instant
aujourd'hui fragilise les intérêts
français au Parlement européen sur tous
les sujets on pourrait parler des
questions d'énergie mais il y a encore
quelques semaines un amendement que je
déposais pour inclure le nucléaire dans
les politiques européennes a été
combattue vigoureusement par les députés
de la majorité macroniste au Parlement
européen on a réussi à le faire passer
mais c'était sans eux et malheureusement
malgré eux donc ce travail là pour
soutenir la voix des Français dans les
institutions européennes il n'est pas
fait par la majorité présidentielle
aujourd'hui il n'est pas fait par
l'Assemblée nationale qui est en réalité
complètement absent des négociations des
débats quand nous avons réussi à faire
obstacle hier avec ma collègue Anne
Sander à ce texte porté par Pascal
Camphin qui allait organiser la
décroissance de l'économie européenne
nous avons réussi à faire obstacle à ce
texte mais c'est nous qui avons déposé
un amendement de rejet c'est notre
groupe qui a fait en sorte que ce texte
puisse tomber et donc ce travail là il
faut que nous puissions le faire avec
plus de force encore il faut que demain
nous revenions plus nombreux au
Parlement européen quand tous les cas il
y est au Parlement européen une droite
française qui assume de défendre une
ligne nucléaire et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est la seule chose qui
compte merci François-Xavier Bellamy
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin on passe au club des
territoires